artificial intelligence is going to be
like a utility it's going to be like a
new electricity it's going to scale
across everything it's going to disrupt
everything I think with the help of
computers soon we're all going to be
able to do amazing things we could never
have dreamed of being able to do before
a significant fraction of our workforce
is ultimately at risk of being left
behind
Automation I say again has always made
regular people red shirt has never made
regular people / now for the main event
arguing for the affirmative again again
the resolution reads robotics will soon
lead to widespread joblessness
underemployment and the concentration of
wealth in the hands of a few defended by
Martin Ford Martin please come to the
stage arguing for the negative Antony
Sam Roffe Antony please come to the
stage Jane please close the voting
martin you've got 15 minutes thank you
very much it's really a pleasure to be
here I thank you to Jean and the other
organizers for putting this together so
for more than a decade now I've really
been focused on the potential
implications of technologies including
artificial intelligence and robotics and
I've really come around to the view that
we're very likely on the leading edge of
a massive disruption in fact I've
written two books that essentially argue
in favor of the resolution that's before
us so I really do think that within 10
to 20 years it's going to be pretty
unambiguous in terms of the impact on
employment markets I also think as I'll
explain later that there's evidence that
this is really beginning to unfold
already and in fact certainly if you
look at the concentration of wealth I
mean there's a lot of evidence there to
see that we're already struggling with
that so I do think this is
issued it's going to be very important
going forward
I want to begin by saying that there are
two ways to to vantage points at which
you can look at this one is through the
lens of Technology you can look at
what's happening with artificial
intelligence and robotics the progress
that's being made the problems that are
being solved and where it's likely to
lead in the relatively near future and
then the other way to look at it is
through the lens of economics and that
primarily we you know it relates to
looking at things like the unemployment
rate and productivity figures and so
forth and I think that both of these
perspectives are very important but I
want to be very upfront in saying that
I'm really someone who comes from a
technology background I look at
technology as the primary driver of this
and I think that ultimately it will be
technology that resolves this question
this is going to be a question for
technology in other words if machines
and algorithms reach the point where
they match or exceed the capability of a
large fraction of our workforce to
really participate in the economy to
contribute to the economy to do work
that has value then we're gonna have a
problem at that point and I think that
you know to my mind that's kind of
inevitable
so I guess another way of saying that is
that I don't believe that there is any
fundamental law of economics that says
this can never happen that we can never
have technological unemployment I don't
think there's any economic law that says
that the vast majority of our available
workforce a ninety-five percent of our
workers are always gonna find a
productive place in the economy that
they're always going to be contributing
to production I think it's entirely
possible that technology will reach a
point where many of those people are
simply going to be displaced and they
won't find a foothold in the future
economy and that's something that we're
gonna have to adapt to now no one is
saying certainly not me that all the
jobs are gonna disappear I'm not saying
that you know everything's gonna be
automated and we're all gonna be on the
street and doing nothing what I am
saying is that a significant fraction of
our workforce
is ultimately at risk of being left
behind and really what we're talking
about for the foreseeable future are
those people who engage in work that is
on some level fundamentally routine and
repetitive and perhaps the best word to
use to describe this is predictable in
other words those people who do the
kinds of work that if you understand
what they've done in the past you can
predict what they're gonna do in the
future so in other words if someone is
coming to work and they're facing
fundamentally the same kinds of problems
again and again so not necessarily rote
repetitive in the sense of standing on
an assembly line and doing exactly the
same things but if you're coming to work
and you face the same challenges again
and again one way to kind of visualize
this that is to imagine if it's the type
of worker where another person could
study a detailed record of everything
they've done in the past could that
other person by studying that record
eventually figure out how to do their
job and if the answer is yes then
there's a good chance that eventually
you'll have a machine learning algorithm
or perhaps a robot that will come along
and basically follow that same path and
also be able to do that job so that's a
job that's gonna be susceptible to
automation and I think if you really
think about it you can see that that's
quite a few jobs there are a lot of
people that do work that will fall into
that category now there have been a
number of attempts to really quantify
that studies that have been done and
looked at this and said you know exactly
how many jobs are susceptible and most
of those studies have come back with
pretty scary numbers they've been
usually in the range to 30 to 50 percent
of all of the jobs in the economy have
the potential to perhaps be automated
maybe within the next 20 years so that's
obviously a lot of jobs it's not all
jobs it's not even most jobs but it's a
huge fraction of jobs and if anything
like that were to be happen if that
number of people were to essentially be
left behind so they do there were no
opportunities for them and they didn't
have the ability to transition into a
role that was in there within their
capability that would be a huge problem
it's something that we have to take very
seriously the other thing I want to
acknowledge right up front
is that this is an issue that has been
raised many times in the past in fact
going all the way back to the Luddite
revolts in England two hundred years ago
people have worried about machines
taking jobs and a specter of
technological unemployment and this is
an issue that's come up again and again
and generally at least in the long term
is turned out to be a false alarm in my
book rise of the robots I actually talk
about the triple revolution report which
I'm gonna guess most of you have
probably never heard of but it was
actually a very prominent report it was
put together by a brilliant group of
people it actually included two Nobel
laureates on the team that wrote this
report and this report was delivered to
the President of the United States and
it argued that the US was on the brink
of total economic chaos and upheaval
because industrial automation was going
to put millions of people out of work
and this report argued that the
government need to take action right
away or else there was gonna be chaos
now that report was given to Lyndon
Johnson in 1964 so over fifty years ago
and of course that didn't really happen
you know things adjusted and things were
okay so I mean it's certainly reasonable
to look at the historical record and be
skeptical at this because the alarm has
been raised so many times in the past
however at a point I will make is that
where technology is concerned this time
is always different that's the entire
point of innovation right that's what
you're trying to do you're trying to
build something new to create something
new to change the game that's what
technology is all about if you go back
to 1903 when the Wright brothers achieve
the first powered flight at the time
that happened there were very prominent
people throughout the world some of the
most famous scientists in the world who
said that what they were about to
accomplish was basically impossible or
at best people said maybe they can do it
as kind of a science experiment or
demonstration but it will never amount
to anything practical obviously that
didn't turn out to be true but at the
time it happened there was an abundance
of evidence to suggest that the skeptics
were correct I mean if you
you can go all the way back to the dawn
of humanity right there was all this
data all this historical evidence saying
the Pym people simply don't get into
mechanical contraptions and fly through
the air there there was every reason to
be skeptical and yet that reality
changed in a few seconds and that's the
nature of technology that's the way it
works and I believe that that is
ultimately the way it's going to work
with artificial intelligence and with
robotics and with the impact that they
are going to have on the job market and
the economy and so this time really is
going to be different and it's because
that's the way technology works now as
we look at the work that has the
potential to be impacted we can start by
looking at what we would call
blue-collar work in other words jobs
that are more manipulative that tend to
be held by workers with relatively you
know lower levels of education and we
can look at for example factory jobs and
of course automation has already had a
massive impact there we've seen huge
numbers of jobs in manufacturing
disappear already because of automation
and if you look at what's happening in
China and now you see millions of jobs
evaporating there because of automation
but what's gonna happen is that the
machines are gonna continue to progress
they're gonna become more dexterous more
capable and they're gonna begin to
encroach on the jobs that remain it
turns out that within these more
manipulative type roles the reason that
jobs so far are safe for people and have
not yet been automated are qualities
like dexterity visual and spatial
perception mobility and eye coordination
so it's not really about general
high-level human intelligence or
problem-solving or blue sky thinking
it's really about the fact that human
beings are actually very good biological
robots we're really good at doing this
manipulative work and so far no one has
been able to build a machine that can
compete at the same level but that is
gradually going to change the machines
are getting better and better just a few
months ago a few months ago
Jeff Bezos said that within a decade he
expected that Amazon would have a
robotic hand that would approach or
match human dexterity so once that
happens that's going to be a game
changer so you're gonna see that kind of
technology begin to impact in factories
in Amazon warehouses in in fast-food
establishments in retail environments
and so forth really across the board so
it's gonna have a dramatic impact and
that's really important because if you
look at the job creation we've seen in
the economy over the past decade it's
been very heavily weighted to those
kinds of service sector lower wage jobs
there's no guarantee that that continues
we can't afford to be complacent about
that at all the technology is gonna have
a big impact on those jobs
then the other side of it is that you
can look at the more cognitive jobs to
high skill jobs very often these are
white-collar jobs these are the jobs
held by university graduates and here
the impact is gonna be at least as large
if you've got a job that is
fundamentally predictable where you're
sitting in front of a computer
manipulating information in some
predictable way cranking out the same
report again and again doing the same
quantitative analysis again and again
writing the same sort of article again
and again if your journal journalist all
of that is already beginning to be
heavily impacted all of those jobs are
gonna be at risk there's gonna be a big
impact there so this is gonna be very
broad-based it's going to impact jobs at
all skill levels across the board it's
not gonna be something specific where
you only hit one area and I think the
fact that it's going to be so broad
based almost like a utility artificial
intelligence is gonna really be like the
new electricity it's gonna scale across
everything and that is one of the
reasons that I really expect this to
have a different outcome to be very very
disruptive now the second way to to sort
of look at this is through the lens of
economics and one thing you might look
at right away is the fact that we do
have right now a very low unemployment
rate we've got an unemployment rate
that's below 4% so can't you just ask
isn't this just kind of absurd why are
we even wearing a
about this I mean unemployment is very
very low right now by historical terms
why where are we even thinking about the
fact that all these jobs are gonna
disappear well one thing that's really
important to keep in mind is that that
headline unemployment rate only captures
workers who are actively looking for
jobs right people are actively looking
for jobs if you go back to 1965 and you
look just at prime working age men so
this would be men over the age of 25 and
under the age of 55 so generally too old
to still be in school but too young to
retire men that we expect generally
would be in the workforce in 1965
ninety-seven percent of those men were
either actually in a job or they were
actively looking for a job now that
number is 89% so rather than its fallen
from ninety seven percent to eighty nine
percent so eleven percent of those prime
working age men right now are completely
disenfranchised from the job market and
there are credible estimates that by
2050 that number could grow to a quarter
or a third so up to a third of men could
complete completely out of the job
market now imagine that you were an
economist in the year 1965 you look out
and you see as you expect 97% of these
men are in the workforce and someone
were to tell you that by 2020 that 3% of
men that's not working is going to grow
to 11% and that beyond that it might
grow to a quarter or even a third it
seems reasonable you might say hey that
sounds like mass unemployment so the
question you can ask is you know we're
debating here the impact of this in the
future is that actually the wrong
question maybe what we should be asking
is if this is actually already happening
maybe the unemployment is all around us
it's here we're just not acknowledging
it because the statistics that we're
looking at are not really capturing it
so I think that there are strong
evidence to say that the impact is
happening already
so finally as I wind this up let me just
say that again I don't think there is
any law of economics that
we can't have technological unemployment
it's entirely possible that what I'm
saying here could turn out to be wrong
but if I'm wrong it will be because I'm
making the same mistake that people have
made in the past which is to assume
technology is going to arrive and then
it doesn't quite get there I if I am
wrong it's not going to be because
there's some hard rule of economics
saying that this simply can't happen
it's really gonna come down to whether
or not the technology arrives and I
think there is very strong evidence to
say that we're getting very close to the
point where this technology is going to
be here and that means that we're gonna
face a significant issue I personally
believe that this is gonna be one of the
biggest challenges we face in the coming
decades and I think that we really need
to start thinking about it very
seriously and what we have to do to
adapt to it
so I will stop there thank you very much
Antony for the negative thank you
everyone for coming thank you
Marcin Thank You Jean okay so if we look
closely at the statement that robotics
will soon lead to widespread joblessness
and the concentration of wealth in the
hands of a few we're being asked to
believe a couple of things here the
first is that the threat that we face is
completely different from before like
say with the Agricole Cultural
Revolution where 79 percent of people
moved out of farms and yet what the they
still found work in the SETI's because
this time the technology is on the brink
of being able to replace almost all
human labor so the resolution says that
this is gonna happen soon and fairly
short or Adar and now the likely result
will be that most people are left
jobless and impoverished well the
benefits of automation just go to you
know the 1% of earners who own the
machines I want to spend the quite a lot
of time focus on this idea that idea
that automation is only going to benefit
the rich and powerful and otherwise does
possess the rest of us and because
that's really the critical
like as automation going to be a good
thing or a bad thing but secondly
because short of having a crystal ball
obviously I can actually prove
conclusively that this time isn't going
to be different
but that's why in philosophy we always
say their burden of proof is on the
positive claim and it's up to Martin to
demonstrate with some hard evidence that
this time really as deferent especially
since you know people have been claiming
this for 250 years he mentioned the
Luddites and then em and 1950s the
philosopher Norbert Wiener warned that
cybernetics was going to displace
everyone nothing happened
even when the synthesizer was invented
there was genuine concern among
musicians unions they protested because
they thought entire orchestras were
going to be replaced by cents so before
we draw the same conclusion we should
ask if there's evidence to em say that
robotics is say replacing jobs faster
than in the past
actually an unemployment they felt a
50-year law in September of 2019 and NS
book Martin said that the number of jobs
then increase in the UK s between 2000
and 2010 and that may have been true but
he was looking at the effects of the
Great Recession of 2008 so since then
employment and the US has gone up by 20
million to record high of 159 million
and 2018 the OECD report the only 10
percent of jobs faced automation resk as
opposed to the EM the 50% the other
paper that Martin mentioned suggests
that and the World Economic Forum
estimated that by 2022 75 million jobs
would be displaced by automation
but 133 million would be gained by a--
so first why is that well I mean for
example an unmanned drone isn't really
unmanned and the US Air Force says that
small one requires a grown crew of 160 E
and a Begg surveillance
strong relies on 300 people and then
they collect dates on then that has to
be analyzed and and there's there's tens
of thousands of them one yes general
said the number one mining problem in
our Air Force as Manning or unmanned
platforms so yeah I love that quote as
well I'm glad ago a lot so um and yeah I
mean while AI can now be a chess master
chance Claire is working whether a I are
even more skillful so I think with the
help of computers soon we're all going
to be able to do amazing things we could
never have dreamed of being able to do
before
and some of us are going to get paid for
them paid for doing those things so and
and and 2017 the information technology
and innovation foundation released a
paper demonstrating that far from
experiencing unprecedented technological
disruption occupational churn in the
u.s. is at the lowest level in American
history at least as far back as 1850
continuing to say that from 1850 to
present the US economy as a whole has
created jobs are a bust rate and
unemployment has been low and the
interesting thing is why they say that
adds it's because they say that
productivity driven increases in
purchasing power for consumers and
business says allow these workers and
firms to produce more so wages go up and
prices goes down and and that in turn
creates more jobs and and new and
existing occupations
now they say there's simply no reason to
believe that the dynamic will change
just because consumer preferences are
far from satisfied I mean we all want
more stuff don't we I know I do as we
say in the economics profession
resources are scarce and human wants are
unlimited
so there's always going to be some
things that people can do to serve other
people so but I'm gonna suppose that
some people no matter how many of these
papers come out and are gonna purse
and thinking that the economists are
woefully naive and too short-sighted to
see that we're in the brink of
technological disaster and to the credit
the past doesn't equal the future
I mean machines used to be created to
aid us like an electric drill or a
forklift whereas no and we've got these
robots and you still need someone to
operate a forklift but you don't need
someone to operate a robot so and Martin
and I agree on one point it's that
that's kind of rival robot revolution is
already happening Jean told me when he
was a young man that he went to the
bowling alley and people replaced the
pens by hand that was one of the the
first robots and then you got ATM and
vending machines and but but the great
thing about them is you can get your
snacks and money around the clock and
they don't have to go to sleep
so effortless but I guess I should say
Martin could be right that this
technology technological revolution does
continue to accelerate but if so why
should it necessarily be a bad thing for
the majority of people because so far
technology has made us retch 99% of the
people who considered pure in America
have electricity running water flush
toilets in a refrigerator these are
thought to be necessities but in the
fifties these were like many these
things were luxuries only 4% of the
adult population was able to afford a TV
and only 3% of a foreign holiday the
life expectancy has gone up by five
years if we spend less time on housework
and chores because we've got Hoover's
and washing machines and dryers and work
hours declined from sixty one per week
in 1870 it's an average of 38.6 today we
could be heading for a three-day weekend
whoo-hoo and you know what that I
certainly want more of those and whether
you know all the new jobs and
hospitality and hotel hearing and you
know whatever as that we do there are
extra day off all of this it's important
to stress that all of this was only a
by advancement and modes of reproduction
because machines allow one person to do
the work of hundreds you know you can
move more stuff for the far left so this
caused upheaval in the short term to be
sure but it's allowed us the you know
the lavish lifestyle that we love today
compared to all of history
so is there any reason to believe that
if Martin's right and the speed of
automation accelerates that the the the
trend of Technology making the average
person more wealthy is just going to
turn around and go back where it came
from and suddenly make us pure instead
let's put the accelerator on and run
through a thought experiment so Tesla
crack the automation of trucking 3.5
million freight jobs just disappear the
estimated savings of this are staggering
a hundred and sixty eight billion who
are those savings going to go to well I
mean
Walmart definitely want the earth share
of the savings so they're really going
to press those trucking companies to
give them knock down rates on the
delivery of services but Walmart are
also in competition with Amazon and
Costco and everyone else who sells our
stuff and those places are also getting
cheaper free so if they want to stay
ahead they're gonna have no choice but
to pass those savings on to you and I so
let's just keep the Fagor simple and say
with these drawings and AI and
productivity doubles the price of your
shopping basket of stuff haves more all
these people who only have to spend half
as much as they do now on their
groceries gonna do with the rest of
their money and what are they gonna
spend it on I mean supposing a toffee
not lotta costs two bucks and Starbucks
instead of four people might decide that
they're willing to go somewhere with a
lot of more ambience I mean I'll happily
pay three dollars for a toffee nut latte
as long as there's someone's playing
Spanish guitar in the cafe and
admittedly in 2020 not many cafes can
afford to pay a Spanish guitarist
but and once the cost of living is
halfed then you can pay them a lot less
and they'll still be able to get by and
in fact in the future plenty of cafes
can afford to hire live musicians
especially now that most of the coffee
making is automated so and that's just a
colorful little illustration and a
having in prices means that a $10 wage
becomes a living wage it's worth $20
that means we're able to afford to pay
people to do a bunch of things we can't
afford to pay them to do now we've been
told for so long that classroom sizes
are too large that hospital waiting
lists are too long that too many old
people languish alone in their houses
with no one to take care of them
we're told that we've created all these
environmental problems and we need green
jobs to save them and to solve them well
I mean clearly that means there's lots
of work to be done and we'd be paying
people to do that work if only we could
afford to well if Martin's right and
automation accelerates very soon we well
be able to afford to what if your block
of apartments was put up by a 3d printer
and the price of your rent halfed what
are you going to do with the finally 11
New York's Etsy right what are you gonna
do with the thousands of dollars that
you save maybe you'll hire someone to
cook your meals and your clothes do your
shopping for you or cheer your children
in maths or look after your grandma I've
been learning a language or an app
called duolingo and if my income my
modest income was worth twice what it
has now I just pay someone to cheer me
some of you learn economics from
podcasts in the future you might just
hire a professional to answer your
questions over Skype and I don't have a
PhD so you know I come and knock down
Ray and Martin's probably a bit pricier
than me he's a beggar fesh so if your
outgoings would were haft what would you
do with the extra money who would you
hire because that's where the jobs are
we need automation
especially with an aging population
we're going to need it to bring down the
soaring price of healthcare the AI can
take on the busy work in the forum
felling so doctors can spend more time
with their patients The Economist Ron
Murray Rothbard had a thought experiment
where he said that the need for human
labor will exist until the point where
as soon as you imagine a sword aah it'll
magically appear in your mouth that
would be a fully automated society
supposing we ever reach a fully
automated society what will people do
for work to ask that question as to mess
the fact that the purpose of work is to
satisfy people's wants and needs we
could create a million jobs tomorrow by
paying 500,000 people to dig a hole and
then another 500,000 people - fela and
again but it wouldn't contribute
anything to human well-being
in other words there's no point people
and people working jobs just for the
sake of it let the ie idea and a fully
automated society everything will be so
abundant that no one needs a job and
it's just like having a replicator from
Star Trek and they gather once once upon
a time buying a garment was a
once-in-a-lifetime event
no the charity shops can't give away all
the claws they get for free matches
which you get complimentary and
restaurants used to be expensive to
produce people give away pens and the
Society of the future everything will be
so abundant that it will be given away
just like a complimentary pen so if you
found a magic lamp with a genie that
granted wishes if it only granted three
wishes you'd have to think pretty hard
on what you wanted but what if you had
unlimited wishes that's Sam that's a
failure that's the replicator from Star
Trek how can anyone be pure in a world
full of replicators so there's a bunch
of reasons why you should vote no on the
resolution and there's no reason to
think that automation will replace all
jobs soon according to the figures
secondly Automation has always made
regular people retch or it's never made
them per hour
and even if automation does accelerate
an unprecedented rate all that means is
we're first headed to a three-day
weekend and then eventually a fully
automated society with replicators and
Star Trek and L greyhawk please and vote
no on the motion thank you very much
[Applause]
Marten five minutes for rebuttal
thank you there's lots we spawn there
I'll try to hit a few points first of
all Antony in the beginning mentioned
agriculture and this is kind of the
classic example people give when they
argue against this it used to be that
most people in the United States and
other countries worked on farms then
along came tractors and combine
harvesters and all the rest and
basically all that work disappeared and
now the percentage of the workforce
engaged in agriculture is between one
and two percent so it is true that
millions and millions of jobs
disappeared however that was a very
specific technology that hit one sector
of the economy just agriculture and what
happened is that those workers
eventually transition to other sectors
of the economy first to manufacturing
and then later on to the service sector
and in each of those cases they went
from doing routine work in fields to
routine work in factories to routine
work in the the service sector so that
was a very specific technology what
we're talking about with artificial
intelligence and robotics again is gonna
be almost like a utility it's gonna be
like electricity let's upping the scales
across everything that impacts the
entire economy across the board and you
know as I explained earlier that really
hits work at all skill levels so it's
much more broad-based
and that's a big part of the reason that
I really do think that this time is
going to be different a second point
would be that of course technology is
going to destroy jobs and it will also
create jobs there's no doubt about that
the question is are those two things
going to balance and I think that there
are good reasons to believe that the
destruction in the future as this new
utility impacts across
the board is gonna outweigh the job
creation and then the second issue there
is what about the match between
opportunities and workers you know jobs
are not interchangeable not everyone can
do every job
people have different talents different
capabilities different skills and not
all of those things are so easy to learn
right you may need to do a certain job
you may need to be creative you may need
very good interpersonal skills you know
you can't can you really take the truck
driver who loses a job and put that
person in charge of caring for an
elderly person is that realistic maybe
not so there are lots of problems that
are gonna come as a result of this and
then finally what I want to say is that
Antony at one point said I think that I
was arguing that automation is a bad
thing and actually I haven't said that
at all I don't think that automation or
artificial intelligence or robotics for
a bad in fact I'm a big proponent of
these technologies I think that that
artificial intelligence is in fact going
to be indispensable in the future I
think that it's going to be one of the
primary tools that we need to rely on in
order to solve some of the biggest
problems that we're gonna face in the
future things like climate change we're
gonna need new sources of energy we're
gonna need ways to adapt to climate
change and so forth artificial
intelligence is gonna make us smarter
it's gonna enable us to take on those
challenges and as an auntie pointed out
artificial intelligence and robotics
will also make things cheaper and that
will help us to alleviate poverty
poverty and so forth but at the same
time people do need an income in order
to have a market economy you need people
to have money to spend that money has to
come from somewhere and if a lot of
people are completely disenfranchised or
if wages are driven down to such a low
rate that people really can't survive
that's gonna be a big problem so I'm not
saying that these technologies are a bad
thing what I am saying is we're gonna
need to adapt to them we're going to
need actual policies that enable us to
adapt to this new reality and I think
the one of the the best ways to do this
one of the most straightforward ways is
something like the universal basic
income which
of course an idea that is now getting a
lot of traction many of you may have
heard of Andrew yang who is running on
this platform of a basic income so
that's really getting a lot of attention
a lot of people are buying into that and
I think that's a great thing so
technology is good automation is good
artificial intelligence is going to be
great but we can't just sit back and let
this unfold and assume it's all gonna be
okay I don't think it will be okay I
think this time is different
and we're gonna need actual policies to
enable us to adapt to this and make sure
that we have inclusive prosperity in the
future so that we don't leave too many
people behind thank you thank you again
okay well I think the fallacy here as
the the market doesn't redistribute the
benefits of automation I think I already
tried to explain that with my analogy of
why the automation of trucking would
need to reflect and lower prices
Mark Martin obviously doesn't think
that's sufficient but I think it
illustrates and the first the first
stage as um everything as every as
everything um has a knock-on effect we
really need to follow the chain of logic
and when people talk about the
government and coming in we need
policies who are these on nation and
gods and government and and think tanks
that actually can predict the future so
accurately that they know what policies
to and to to implement to help I mean
for me personally the idea of a basic
income that's just going to end up in
the government for me I I see a
dystopian science fiction novel where
the government starts threatening you to
take away your basic income if you don't
sort your recycling and then you know if
we're going to war with Iran if you
don't sign up for the draft they're
going to take away
basic income that's like one of the
scariest ideas in the world as the
government having the the control over
$12,000 on everyone's purse strings
andrew yang might may not be tempted to
abuse that but you know
lord knows who gets in four years later
if it's someone more authoritarian than
Trump then you never know what's going
to happen with that I think that I I
just I don't think and Martin's
adequately addressed the point on my
falling price says in a gradual
cascading way and well he did mention
sorry that say a trucker's not gonna
look after grandma I should probably
address that that's a good point you
know maybe I talkers not gonna look at
after grandma but the point is that them
that someone is and the money that you
save from truckin being automated as as
the money that you will pay someone to
look after Brahma in the meantime the e
eyes are people are already will usually
learning things through apps it's going
to be easier than ever for the trucker
to retrain and if you were going to who
n a policy and to a rather than give
everyone a universal basic income you
could give an income for a year to
displaced workers that we have far and
more moderate and a moderate solution to
that rather than risk biasing the higher
the entire economy and with it with a
with a basic income
so yeah the trucker might know find a
job looking after grandma but he is
likely to find a job doing something
well the number of hours that we each
need to work continues to fall because
machines and AI are doing all the left
thing for us as I said many of us might
be working with AI and the Martin Ford's
the the other Ford's obviously automated
said the production line and employed
more people and double their wages and
made automobiles affordable to everyone
now it's very skilled to make a car from
scratch but it's not very skilled to
work on a production line AI is going to
have a similar effect where those people
who don't have skills and actually
working aided by the technology as are
going to be able to do a whole bunch of
things that they weren't able to do
before so but that's why I stress again
that is even in the interim if the long
term is going to hyper mechanized
Society which you know given that given
if we don't blow each if we don't blow
ourselves up it might happen in a
thousand or 2,000 years or it might
happen in 50 years that's not gonna be a
bad thing that's not going to make
everyone / that's going to be make
everyone wretch because we'll have so
much stuff coming out the 3d printers
they won't even be able to give away and
thank you very much well thank you to
both of you we now get to the question
and answer part of the the evening I
want to use a madres prerogative to ask
a couple of questions of each of you and
you people can be lining up to ask your
questions I'll be yielding the floor to
you very shortly
Anthony would you address perhaps you
have addressed it but maybe I would like
to hear from you to dress as well again
Martin's point that that not necessarily
that that even 50% of the jobs are going
to be replaced but if I heard him
correctly you know 30% 40% that is
indeed watch but joblessness if that
happens and so he said that but then
he's also specifically said that then
that that anything that's predictable
but be it brain work or
or or lower-level work predictable work
which he would argue is about easily one
third of the work that people do is
going to be replaced by machines could
you address that concern of his and
nerdy gonna be priced yeah well again
it's not comparable to the percentage of
people who were displaced by the
agricultural revolution what those
people do we don't know yet there was no
such thing as a cat-scan operator before
the cat scan was invented there was no
such thing as a microchip assembler
before we could assemble microchips we
needed the machines so I don't really
know what jobs are gonna replace the
jobs that we do now
but the point adds that jobs are not for
the sake of jobs they're for the sake of
meeting people's needs and the
preference says the more stuff the more
stuff the robots and I make the more
wealth there is you don't have to give
people money so that they can go out and
buy a because the price of these goods
and services is going to plummet and you
know if it gets the point where em
people can't afford at that level the
price just continues to plummet and
people will give away the machines that
make the that make the products because
what use is holding on to it so I'm not
afraid of automation in fact and I think
that it's it's necessary for it to see
the end of poverty Martin do you want to
address that or do you want me comment
at all sure this thing about falling
prices I don't think it really solves
the problem for one thing obviously if
you don't have an income or if your
income is extremely load and even
falling prices don't solve the problem
right if you if you're unemployed with
no income you still need money to buy
two things the second issue more broadly
than that is that even if if what entity
says is true what you're talking about
is sustained deflation scaling across
the whole economy you've got essentially
what you're saying is that well maybe
you'll be jobless or maybe your wages
will fall to a very low level but the
prices of everything
you want are gonna fall even more that's
not an optimistic scenario that's a
disaster I mean that there's no time in
history when sustained deflation has
been a good thing you you think it's a
disaster Martin that if your income
falls by 20% but if prices fall by 70%
you call that a disaster across the
whole economy absolute reason it the
reason maybe two reasons one is that
that kind of deflation across the whole
economy no one can pay their debts
anymore so you'll have their one that's
their dad that's right debts don't don't
deflate well what if it happens slowly
they're falling the debts are paid off
slowly doesn't happen right away you if
you're if your income is falling below
what you can service your debt I mean
that's exactly what happened in 2008
right the second thing that happens in
that scenario is that no one buys
anything because tomorrow it's gonna be
cheaper it is that what happened with
computers there they keep falling they
don't in that point in place well across
the whole economy don't I mean that
that's all right computers you only buy
it every year right I have a question
for you all right we're coming and that
my only question for you is if there is
indeed a three-day weekend and if there
isn't either huge need as you said to
take care of granny
the truck driver can't do it do you see
the potential the real need for things
that we can't afford to be affordable if
there's a advance in technology there to
create jobs that in in the the sector of
entertainment hospitality hotels
three-day weekend taking care of granny
do you see a lot of jobs potentially
created in that way in those sectors do
you I'm sorry um yes absolutely
but probably not enough to solve this
problem and and and again you've got
that mismatch issue right you know not
everyone has got the talent the
personality
how about hospitality hotels cruise
ships all of that entertainment stuff
yeah again I don't think anywhere
everyone can do and I'm very doubtful
that they're gonna be it
in a world where all the jobs disappear
and and wages are falling that we're
building all these cruise ships I mean
why would you think that okay questions
yeah I think from what I know we don't
see dramatic economic productivity
increases or like dramatic increases in
rates of automation currently do you
agree with that and if so do you think
that's because it just hasn't happened
yet or some other reason it's not a
question for Martin mostly for mark yeah
there is kind of a paradox with the
productivity that's been pointed out
before people used to say that when
computers first showed up there was no
evidence of that in the productivity but
then around 1995 we did see a big surge
in productivity so there was a
significant delay there in essence it
took some time for businesses to
assimilate that to figure out how to use
computers and then you saw the
productivity surge I think you'll
probably see the same thing with
artificial intelligence
another point would be that we have over
the last decade or two seen a revolution
in technology but it hasn't primarily
been artificial intelligence it's been
the Internet has been social media and
you can see that there are some aspects
of that that would increase productivity
but there also some that would it would
force it down right I mean who thinks
that having Twitter at work increases
the productivity of workers I think it
actually certainly decreases them so
there are a lot of things on both sides
but I do think that as artificial
intelligence becomes more powerful and
is assimilated into business models that
you'll you'll probably begin to see that
comment or do you want pass okay next
question
Martin you've mentioned policy as but
you only mentioned universal basic
income as a solution for this
joblessness that you're predicting do
you have any other ideas on what
policies would do that like retraining
and Anthony do you see any private
market solutions for the job of this
joblessness if it does happen
I'm skeptical that reach I mean I think
we should absolutely invest in
retraining and and community colleges
and things like that to enable as many
people as possible to adapt to this but
I'm skeptical that that solves the
problem I you know I I think the problem
is bigger than that so I do think
ultimately we probably need something
like a basic income maybe not now but at
some point in the future there are other
proposals out there like a guarantee of
jobs you know a government guarantee of
jobs and I think if you're a libertarian
that should really terrify you you know
a basic income is way better than having
the government create jobs and have a
huge bureaucracy to to manage all those
jobs right so I I think honestly there
are a lot of libertarians that support a
basic income and I think you know
Friedrich Hayek supported a guaranteed
minimum income for example so I think
that from that perspective it's probably
the best overall solution that you can
hope for comment well I agree that the
government making the job as probably
worse than a basic income but as we like
to see in Glasgow where I'm from being
punched is better than being stabbed and
thousands and the the problem with
government making job programs as they
just never succeeded in the past the job
government doesn't know what the hell to
train people are the only way to get
people into these jobs is to actually
make it lucrative for businesses to
train people now I personally I'm not
gonna pay you $15 an hour and while I'm
training you to get nothing back and
then once you've got the training you
just go work for someone else so and my
opinion there needs to at least be
minimum wage exemptions for a period
Wales staff are being trained then you
got all these extra expenses which the
government and X imposes upon employing
people and payroll tax says the labor
laws and some cases and exec strikes
pants don't necessarily do the job
they're meant to do mandatory and medic
medical contributions which
taxes amp so people get are paid more
and they're over insured they're paid
more in medical insurance where actually
they might just like the money in their
pocket quite frankly so and think the
government can get the way and make it
cheaper for business says to train
people so that those people can find
work and that's the best way to the
market we'll find out what people should
be working at there's no no one on
nation in government - to choose that
they can see forward what to train un
thank you oh this question is for both
of you guys but I got more of a gist
from Anthony maybe but what is your
worst case scenario for automation yeah
I guess I don't know the worst case
scenario is like keV of the termini or
for automation I don't really understand
the question like I guess the worst case
scenario is that some maniac gets an AI
or the yeah well actually I think what
we should do is we should just ask the
AI how to solve the problem because the
AI is so as obviously going to be and so
much so so surpassing human intelligence
that maybe that can tell us what to do
well in economic turns putting aside the
the Terminator if in economic turns the
worst case scenario is that we have
widespread joblessness or we have wages
driven to very low levels and we may
well as people have pointed out have
falling prices for products and services
as well but that's again that's
deflation that's that's a depression
that's what that's what the Great
Depression looked like that's not a good
scenario okay and because the economy
just get smaller and smaller under that
that situation so we really have a
economic crisis a financial crisis and I
think that that that would be quite
disastrous next question this question
is for Anthony and I suppose dovetails
off the previous one but it didn't seem
to me that you really in
aged with the most severe manifestations
of the thought experiment so you're to
say well um if you consider drones right
now the problem is not that we have
drones but we don't have enough people
Manning those drones and similarly
truckers may not have jobs but think
about all the money that's going to be
saved and then they can just take that
money and give those to other people
with other jobs but you know if you
could just struggle with the possibility
where none of these jobs exists so we're
Amazon's a robotic arm really
systematically takes over positions that
would otherwise not be filled and there
are no other jobs to pay people to do
and secondly I'm just wondering if you
have any thoughts on you know whether or
not there would be some sort of
existential identity crisis for people
who just don't have work so instead of a
three-day weekend suddenly we have a
seven-day weekend what would that do to
the morale of society yeah thanks those
are great questions well I'm sorry that
I didn't adequately address the first
one cuz I tried really hard which was to
say that I forgets that point where
there's no jobs because AI in robots can
do everything then the goods and
services which those AI and robots
produce will be so abundant that they'll
be worth nothing I mean I mean you know
my laptop as in 30 years you know you
you can't give away
it's so-so the second part of your
question was compelling and sorry could
you just remind me all that again it's
harder being up here than you think yeah
we existential thing that's a great
question well that's what you know I'm a
man I I work in mental health I'm not
just an economics journalism or saw a
therapist so these kind of things are
really interesting to me the meditation
apps and and so forth what have you now
this is we are at a point where we have
existential dread I agree with you
because we choose who we marry and you
may not remind the right person we have
to choose our job your ancestors didn't
choose their job they just did whatever
they want to do so at some point we're
going to put the technology the arms the
AI
and all our technology to work
to discover how we can advance human
wellbeing and I think that as where
things are going now because see when
everyone was poor and they were
miserable
they thought they were measurable
because they were pure now it's the rich
people that are measurable so I'm not
obviously not measurable because I'm
pure it must be something to do with me
so that's where we're going I think and
I hope we are as a human species the
only business is the business of human
well-being and how do we deal with you
know the human condition and I think
that we're gonna see more and more stuff
coming out to help us with that in terms
of technology like for one example I saw
a few years ago they were trialing a
sort of virtual reality game where they
put electrodes on your head and it
monitors how relaxed you are and the
more you start as an amoeba and your
creature evolves and the more relaxed
you become the more the creature evolves
on the screen so it's actually using
sort computer software to teach people
how to relax so I'd love to see more and
more stuff like that maybe um the e I'll
teach you yoga as well so you don't come
become a couch potato with all that time
you spent in virtual reality you want to
dress that Martin yeah I do think that
there's a real issue in terms of that
existential type crisis I mean you can
look for example at the opioid epidemic
we have in the United States there has
been shown to be a correlation between
that and joblessness so this is
something we're gonna have to struggle
with you know what people need is not a
job per se what people need is a purpose
they need to feel they're contributing
they need to feel that they're doing
something important they need to feel
that if they weren't there they would be
missed and you know in modern times for
the most part for most people a job is
what has provided that so I can sort of
imagine a future where you know incomes
kind of be become decoupled from that
that sense of purpose so maybe you won't
have a job that provides both the income
and the sense of purpose as a package
maybe you'll get the income from a basic
income and you'll be doing other things
maybe you'll be volunteering in the
community or whatever to give you
that sense that you're doing something
important but it's it's absolutely a
problem that we're gonna have to solve
going forward as we face this question
so with a number of job losses in the
past
was it really automation that caused
those job losses or the jobs just move
to places with higher performance lower
welfare and the more efficient
government can we blame automation for
those job losses and did the jobs just
go offshore well I'm I guess I wish the
EM those places where they have the
sweatshops would have more open markets
so that more companies would go in and
bed up the price of wit em wages there
and we could we could see our uneven
faster and reduction in poverty
worldwide I don't know to what extent
jobs are going offshore and to what
extent they're being em they're being
affected by automation but what I do
know is that to the extent you have a
free market there's always going to be a
drive to pass the savings on to
consumers and eventually Bangladesh will
be are well and and an easier one you
know won't be per countries anymore
they're already going in the right
direction and I'll be great when we see
the end of poverty coming yeah um
economists have looked at this and it's
you know it's a complex picture but in
general they found that Ottaway
automation tends to outweigh
globalization
however it's it's absolutely true that
jobs do move offshore but actually you
can look at China and jobs have moved
from the u.s. to China but now they're
being automated in China you can also
look at very low wage countries like
Vietnam or Indonesia and what you're
seeing there is reshoring where for
example a shoe factory from being run by
Nike or adidas will be shut down in
Indonesia and we sure to the United
States or Germany but then of course
that factory is almost fully automated
so automation is
is ultimately gonna overwhelm
globalization and you're gonna see a
return of factories to to be in
proximity to markets next question no I
just wondering the extent to which you
would see say we're talking about the
United States in particular or even on a
global scale Fed monetary policy playing
a role either is a pre-emptive action in
superseding robotic takeover of jobs or
accelerating it yeah I mean it does tie
into the question if there's money to
expansion and prices can remain stable
and wages can rise young but if they if
they expand the money supply but you
want to deal with that question right
well I you know I do think that in
general I've talked a lot about
deflation a kind of environment where
basically if people don't have money to
spend or if the distribution of income
is so concentrated that most people are
kind of struggling and only a few people
have money to spend then you've got less
demand in the whole economy right
there's there's simply less customers
out there and so you've heard economists
like Larry Summers talking about what he
calls secular stagnation which is
basically where there's not much demand
there's not there aren't productive
opportunities companies sit on money and
that's exactly the kind of scenario
where the Fed keeps interest rates very
very low money kind of sloshes around
it's not getting into productive
opportunities and so forth so I think
this all kind of ties in and to some
extent that that is related comment well
companies make stuff to sell that stuff
so they need to look at you know what
people are able to buy and want to buy
and post your mouth yeah as far as
monetary policy is concerned yeah I
think the printing of money has been a
complete disaster I don't agree with
Martin Ford that em deflation is a bad
thing this country had deflation for a
hundred years before he had the Federal
Reserve the price of everything went
down by 20% and people got richer and
it's just basically and the idea that
deflation as a bad thing is probably
just some property
to defend the Federal Reserve from for
all their inflating the currency and
handing out and the money to the wretch
and politically-connected first and yeah
printing money as a as punishing people
who were responsible and saved and
rewarding people or encouraging people
to go into debt it's disastrous on
several fronts
next question even if the bulk of
low-skilled job displacement is due to
automation a certain amount is also due
to outsourcing and low skill immigration
so given that would either of you
support policies like higher tariffs or
stricter immigration laws we're gonna
have a debate about tariffs I'm going to
be debating Steve more of the Trump
administration next month on tariffs I'm
not in favor of tariffs I think Steve is
so maybe it was this table the tariffs
thing and then we did to have it debate
on immigration
so guys I'm not gonna ask you to deal
with those two excellent questions
because the sole forum has already
addressed them next question so I work
at the kind of the intersection of IOT
and AI and commercial real estate and
it's sort of tangential to manufacturing
so I've seen the application of this
really what I'm seeing is the
streamlining of lowering of cost of
goods sold increase in product quality
which ultimately gets passed through
that a consumer on the purchasing power
side add in quantum computing in terms
of materials discovery pharmaceuticals
discovery and it seems like it would be
a net benefit to society which gets the
question of lower cost of goods sold
higher quality product ultimately leads
to cheaper costs of capital and with
more availability on capital it allows
businesses to hire more and at least
sustain or minimize job loss on a macro
level have you thought at all in terms
of cheaper cost of capital and what that
means in terms of preventing massive job
loss
now you want a dress that sounds like
it's question for you entering shape a
cost of capital and what about by AI I
think it's good when companies invest
and machines and factories to make stuff
because the stuff gets cheaper and more
abundant
i I I don't know the degree to which the
effect is on capital and to the III
don't have your your firsthand expertise
you know my your knowledge on the ground
my expertise is e in economics theories
and and I saw ok I see as applied in the
real world okay I'll just say that what
you said there was a lower cost of
capital allows businesses to hire more
people
it's not about allowing them to hire
more people it's about do they need
those people do they want to hire those
people and if in fact that the cost of
capital was lower they can also invest
that in machines and if the machines are
capable of doing more what the people
would be doing they're gonna probably
prefer that right so it's really a
question of the trade-off between
technology and and workers and what
they're each capable of and as machines
get better and better businesses will
choose to invest more in technology next
question
oh you want to score you want to comment
all right just on that point
what's the isn't it better to have ten
factories with a hundred people owned by
ten different entrepreneurs than one
factory with a thousand people when that
increased competitiveness also push cost
of goods down more increase economic
activity and again prevent massive job
loss I'm you saying the cheaper cost of
capital causes more companies to buy
pension funds banks will lend in more
businesses if they can lend at a lower
rate I've seen more businesses which
means you can produce more factories
sure with more machines and you have 10
people in a factory instead of a hundred
we have ten factories actually the
balance it still balances out it seems
all right I mean that sounds reasonable
but I the evidence doesn't suggest that
we're moving to a more distributed sort
of balkanized economy in that way the
evidence suggests they
are becoming more concentrated that
businesses are getting larger and larger
right there are a lot of people talking
about antitrust issues with the big tech
companies and so forth so okay well
thank you for your comments
next question whenever I like to see
articles about AI it seems like it's
always ten years away or you know some
like bit large enough timeframe that
it's kind of far enough away but do you
so do you have any evidence that like
this sort of job loss disruption will
come that fast like there's a big
difference between 50 percent job loss
over 10 years than 50 percent spread
over 50 years do you want to come in
yeah I I mean as I said Jeff Bezos just
said that within 10 years they're gonna
have a robotic hand that can approach
human dexterity we see a revolution in
what's called deep learning the specific
sphere of artificial intelligence that's
really showing the most progress right
now you've got systems that can
outperform radiologists reading
mammograms and and finding is there
cancer there so there's definitely very
real examples you can give of how this
is happening already and I absolutely
expected that's going to accelerate over
the next 10 20 years
comment mantain coming yeah I think it'd
be wonderful if there's more
applications and medicine like radiology
since you know healthcare in America is
through the roof and I think I think
you're right that is the crux of the
question is this gonna happen soon
technology takes a long time through
although and even if we don't if if we
banned inventing anything new tomorrow
for 20 years we life on earth would
still be recognizable unrecognizable 20
years for now because we just find new
things to do with the technology that we
already have so it does take a long time
to roll technology out you need to get
them in production so I think soon as an
important word in the resolution and I
don't see it happening that soon and it
could happen eventually yes
actually kind of continuing with that
talk about radiology and kind of like
more skilled jobs rather than looking at
like a simple service person like a yeah
the help desk employee or something like
that being replaced by a virtual
assistant instead of looking at
something more skilled when those
employees really leave the workforce
someone that's skilled but kind of that
9 to 5 employee do you really feel them
or find that they'll be able to pick up
the skills fast enough
it's a pivot in the industry as it
changes as it kind of grows it really
depends how free the market as if it's
difficult and expensive to employ people
and too expensive to train them then
it's going to make it more difficult we
have time for one more question so this
will have to be the last question all
right thank thank you it's good it
sounds good in theory that the truck
drivers who will be displaced can be
retrained community colleges and all or
other routine jobs that would need
retraining in Manhattan we have BMCC
25,000 students the Kingsborough is
10,000 students you go into the where
the truck drivers live and in the
country there might be five community
colleges and a whole state so how do you
retrain these people where are these
teachers going to come from or would
there be UC resurgence in rural real
estate is that going to be a good
investment well I just don't say I think
the colleges are completely divorced for
from the market like how did those
teachers and colleges know what to train
people and the best training is
on-the-job training and the only
employers know what they need people
with what skills they need their
employees to have in order to make money
from their employees so the best that's
all I can say the best training is
on-the-job training so it needs to be
affordable to companies to retrain the
truckers and to the extent of the marque
the free or the labor market the easier
be for those truckers to find new work
yeah but it's wrong yeah we're out of
time I'm afraid for the Q&A Martin if
you want to adjust that particular
question maybe do it in your summation
we're now going to the summation for a
part of the evening Martin take it away
for your salvation yeah so to address
that I think that again I'm skeptical of
retraining I think we should do
everything we can
[Music]
retraining programs were put in place as
a result of globalization an offshoring
and generally they were an abject
failure they didn't work very well so we
should do what we can but it's probably
not gonna be enough and that's why I
really do think that eventually we're
gonna need something along the lines of
a guaranteed minimum income or a basic
income maybe not now not five years from
now but within ten years or so I think
that it's going to become almost
inevitable that we're gonna have to move
in that direction to give people an
income so that they can participate in
the economy so they can be consumers so
that we can continue to have a thriving
market economy you've got to have people
with money to spend in order to make
that happen so again I want to emphasize
that I do think that there is gonna be
an impact on it on employment I don't
think there's any fundamental economic
law to say that this can't happen but I
don't I'm not arguing it's a bad thing I
think it's a different thing I think
it's something that we have to adapt to
I think we're gonna have to change the
rules of our economy we're gonna have to
actively make sure that there's a
mechanism to distribute purchasing power
and income to all the people out there
because right now the mechanism that
gets money into the hands of people so
that they can spend money and keep
driving the economy is jobs as those
jobs erode or those jobs become less
effective the wages fall we're gonna
have to figure out something else and I
think that a basic income is very likely
the the most straightforward way to do
that so again I think that this is going
to be a very broad-based
phenomenon we're going to see an impact
across the board at all levels of work
everything from blue-collar very
low-level unskilled work all the way up
to radiologists you know a radiologist
needs an enormous amount of training
you've got to go to university then
you've got to go to medical school then
you need at least five years of
residency beyond that so it's an
incredible amount of human capital there
but nonetheless this is a job that can
be probably automated in a very near
future so we need to really keep that
perspective this is not something that
is only going to impact some small
groups of people in the economy only
some types of workers it's going to be
very very broad-based it's going to
scale across our entire workforce and I
think ultimately it's really gonna to
demand a solution and I do think that
the kinds of things for example I
mentioned Andrew yang earlier I think
that this is a very very important
conversation for us to have I think that
over the next couple of decades the
challenge of making sure that we build
an inclusive future in a world where a
lot of people are at risk of being left
behind is really going to rise to one of
our most fundamental challenges is gonna
be almost at the level of something like
climate change and so I think these are
very very important discussions to have
I think that we all need to keep an open
mind about this we need to recognize
that the technologies that are being
developed now really are different the
thing that I keep emphasizing is that
artificial intelligence is going to be
like a utility it's going to be like a
new electricity it's gonna scale across
everything it's going to disrupt
everything it's not going to be like
what happened with agriculture or what
happened with the early days of
manufacturing is going to be much more
broad-based than that and so we're gonna
have to view it in a different way but I
do think that if we can adapt to this if
we can finally put policies in place
that build an inclusive future for
everyone then it then it's all good I'm
very optimistic I think that we can have
the kind of scenario that I think
Antonia has alluded to you know a
post-scarcity economy the Star Trek
the world where people have a lot more
leisure time where they have generally a
better life but my main point is that
that is not going to happen
automatically I think we're gonna need
explicit policies to make sure we move
in that direction thank you very much I
think it is going to become happen
automatically yeah sorry that's just my
scores a sense of humor sometimes I joke
when I'm nervous okay so I feel like
that as the the function of the market
to roll that Star Trek society out and
as the interventions into the market
which slow down the process like the
printing of money like him the
over-regulation
and that makes it hard for people in
capital to move around so and I thank
you for your kind attention
Thank You Marcin for coming and debating
me let's look at the let's look closely
at the motion again robotics will soon
lead to widespread sorry I told you I'm
a joker I laugh when I'm nervous right
the terminator robotics will soon lead
to widespread joblessness and the
concentration of wealth in the hands of
the few
robotics will soon lead to widespread
joblessness as I detailed in my
presentation with some papers some
references to papers and things there's
no evidence that this is happening
faster in the past that doesn't mean
that it can't start happening faster it
can but there's no reason to think that
it's that this is going to happen soon
so that's an important point
Automation I I say again has always made
regular people richer as
ever made regular people per hour so I
don't see a reason to think that it's
going to turn around and go back the way
that it came from and suddenly
automation is going to make everyone
pure even a em replace says millions of
workers it's doing that because to
produce things the capitalists are
essentially implementing the technology
to produce things to sell them to people
now if people don't have the money to
buy them then the those products are
just going to come down and down and
down in price they don't want it them
sitting in a warehouse that they have to
pay to as to further maintenance of so
so if there's lots and lots of stuff
made then the same way that you get a
complimentary box with matches when you
go into a nice restaurant today or a
hotel lobby there you know they will
give you an iPad and you know if things
are that abundant what are we gonna do
with all this stuff the only reason why
we have an economy is because goods and
services are scarce
if goods and services are hyper abundant
because they're created by a AI and by
machines
then they're essentially and you know
worth less they're they're essentially
you can give them away you can be em so
even if automation remember the motion
says soon as it's going to happen soon
but ever eventually accelerates to this
point an unprecedented rate all that
that there's no reason to think that
that will concentrate wealth in the
hands of the few that will do what it's
always done which is make luxuries like
an automobile refrigerator am a la
computer em a Nokia phone is more
powerful than the computer that landed
on the
that land that the moon lander and the
moon so oh this acceleration of
automation is going to do what it's
always done which is to make products
that were once luxuries a force or
abundant that they're available to
everyone so thank you very much and
please vote against the motion because I
I've proven it's wrong so thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you to both for spirited
and and friendly exchange which is
always the standard that we want to meet
at this so forum Jane is opening the
voting again and so please cast your
final vote robotics will soon lead to
widespread joblessness underemployment
and the concentration of wealth in the
hands of a few yes no or still undecided
a couple of announcements we we will be
having they debate between William
Kristol and Scott Horton on foreign
policy on Sunday evening May 10th and we
switched that from May 11th because we
were able to rent a large hall at the
new school 800 seats for that event
we're already selling big time for it
and Jane issued a bulletin to those that
bought tickets for the 11th to tell you
that it will be on the evening of the
10th the Sunday the 10th a William
Kristol and Scott Horton have both
agreed to appear on may 10th but if for
any reason you can't make it on the 10th
we will give you a full refund again
we've sold hundreds of tickets to that
event william of crystal as many of you
know yeah is a very prominent person in
the field of foreign policy
Scott Horton also has a pretty huge
following so that Sunday evening May
10th when you mentioned two tariffs on
that our next event
on Tuesday February 4th Heritage
Foundation Distinguished Fellow Steven
Moore also an advisor to the Trump
administration will defend the
resolution president Trump's trade
related initiatives against China
deserves broad public support he will
defend the affirmative and I will be on
the negative it with respect to that
resolution guest moderator will be Nick
Gillespie that's our next event on
February on Tuesday February 4th on
Monday March 7th we mentioned antitrust
Columbia Law Professor Tim Wu author of
the curse of bigness will defend the
resolution antitrust should take the
initiative to control the size of the
big tech companies against NYU Law
Professor Richard Epstein there will be
another sort of sole forum event in
Washington DC that will be on April 3rd
Friday afternoon it will be sponsored by
Liberty con Liberty con will be a
weekend event it's an annual weekend
event in Washington DC and I've been
invited on Friday afternoon just prior
to the event so I'll go warm up act to
debate the resolution for capitalism to
survive the US government must take a
proactive role in directly addressing
the problem of inequality that
resolution will be defended by pillared
surprise winning journalist Steven
Pearlstein and I will be taking the
negative that's April 3rd if you're
going to Liberty con-com you can buy
tickets you'll find there'll be whole
galaxy of people speaking through that
weekend on Saturday Sunday that includes
I know John Mackey includes Kathryn
mango ward of Reason and I'm now if this
noticing that Jane has the final results
and the tootsie rolls are out here
gentlemen because you know that if it's
a tie you both get it tootsie roll if
it's a winner you are only one side gets
the tootsie roll oh so we'll see what
happens
okay yeah well you both picked up votes
the the yes vote picked up went from 16
nearly 17% to 19.6% you picked up two
point six points for the yes vote the no
vote went from 50 to 69 picked up 19
points and so apparently the noes have
it
and apparently ingenue gets the to 0
[Applause]